I'm shook we're here to tell my daughter
a secret that is probably at this point
thirty years old it's something that I
think will she'll find surprising and
out of character I feel like my kids
always pretty much to know everything
anyways but this one secret wasn't going
on for quite a while he does some
strange stuff it could be anything I
mean they know that I'm gay but they
don't know what that means in my life
really I've kind of kept them sheltered
from that I don't know if that's true
but okay he has a video on YouTube
called I'm gay gay I'm an open book with
her I still feel like there's a lot that
I haven't heard about my dad I'm gonna
be honest and I really feel like there's
some wild stuff you know I just need to
tell him you know that I've been going
to karaoke right you kind of stopped but
I know that I did stop but like every
Monday I was there I'm I'm a drag
performer I have like a total drag
persona I know you know that I'm gay and
that I dress up every once in a while
and what's the name her Linda her Linda
I'm ready you ready yeah okay
being a doctor right you know you know
that I told you always want to do it
from the time I was a little kid yeah as
long as I could possibly remember yeah
after the end of my second year I had
been named chief resident for the third
year yeah and I quit the program
entirely yeah what I quit
I resigned I not only resigned from
being chief resident I resigned from
medicine I quit wait are you kidding me
not kidding you whoa this is my baby I
have no idea what I was gonna do I just
I literally just couldn't take it
anymore so then so you quit which is a
word that doesn't apply to him ever do
you want to see her sure oh man you know
it's just not that surprising because he
used to do drag every Halloween I just
sat down I talked
the mom about it and I said you know
this just doesn't feel right that even
though I'm miserable and this is
horrible it's just two more years I'm
halfway done so when I came to them and
said look I've reconsidered and I'm
gonna come back they were happy to have
me back this is like a huge chunk of
like family story that I've been missing
he just does a lot of things right and I
think my dad's like the smartest person
and like the most dedicated person so
it's nice to know that when he was
around my age he did a really terrible
huh really bad and you know what the
biggest life lesson that my dad tells my
sister and I don't quit are you good I'm
I think I'm pretty good I've got a
little bit of a following do I get to
come now yeah you need to come on to
come see you do dragon I feel like I've
just my second coming out but I
appreciate that you're not being
judgmental well you weren't the
prettiest girl I'd ever seen but better
than that
rising from the dead as Taylor Swift
says or what she says oh yes yes oh
there was there was another secret oh no
I hate to tell you about my closet I
have a playlist there's gonna take mom
to the show yeah when she went to choose
tours for this album I just hope he's
good at it cuz it's a little bit more
embarrassing if he's bad I need a good
drag queen dad and not a bad one does
this make you look at me different yes
just like out of the two people sitting
here like who would you guess that's
good that it's out there but it's a
little strange it was nice having my own
little life basically what he just said
it's the reason he didn't tell me is
because he didn't want me cramping his
style this was a good experience
yeah I have plenty to use against you
now okay a lot of ammo I'm not
embarrassed oh I think they'll probably
still be more secrets I think we can
have our own lives you gotta keep
secrets sometimes
[Music]